the ice rink across the street from my
house the tennis court during the summer
and then they put boards up in the
winter time and freeze it yeah I paid
some house leagues and [ __ ] but I've
been playing lately again you were
playing hockey before like while you're
making this album yeah it's like me and
like three other people who played two
on two with a goalie and then I'll leave
after I win and I'll go to the studio
and take a shower and just work you get
any inspiration like on the rink nah not
really but I'll be wearing like my chain
and my watch and my jewelry when I'm on
the ice how's the skill set the only
thing that gets the best of you is my
stamina everything else is good handling
everything's good defense all that
there's one thing that you had to say is
like I want to do this what is it I
don't want to play like ice hockey like
practice with the Leafs oh you know
anyone in the organization well Austin
Matthews will be talking to tell them a
little bit let you get out there to get
some slap shots off hell yeah I got
zingers